does the following table represent a
linear equation so let's see what's
going on here when X is negative 7 y is
4 then when X is negative 3 y is 3 so
let's see what happened toward what our
change in X was so our change in X and I
could even write it over here our change
in X so going from negative 7 to
negative 3 we had an increase in 4 and X
and what was our change in Y and this
triangle that's just the Greek letter
Delta it's shorthand for change in well
our change in Y when X increased by 4 we
went our Y value went from 4 to 3 so our
change in Y is negative 1 now in order
for this to be a linear equation the
ratio between our change in Y and our
change in X has to be constant so our
change in Y over change in X for any two
points on in this equation or any two
points at the table has to be the same
constant when when exchanged by for Y
changed by negative 1 or when Y changed
by negative 1 X changed by 4 so it has
to be we have to have a constant change
in Y with respect to X of negative 1/4
let's see if this is true so the next
two points when I go from negative 3 to
1 once again I'm increasing X by 4 and
once again I'm decreasing Y by negative
1 so we have that same ratio now so
let's look at this last point when we go
from 1 to 7 in the x-direction we are
increasing by 6 and when we go from 2 to
1 we are still decreasing by 1 so now
this ratio for the slot going to this
last from this third point to this
fourth point is negative 1 over 6 so it
is not so 4 just for this last point
right over here for this last point our
change in Y over change in X or I should
say really between these last two points
right over here our change in Y over
change in X let me clear this up our
change in let me make it clear so just
between these last and magenta just
between these last two points over here
our change in Y is negative 1 and our
change in X is 6 so we have a different
rate of change of Y with respect
X because we had a different rate of
change of Y with respect to X or ratio
between our change in Y and change in X
this is not a linear equation no not a
linear equation